je vous rappelle les règles ils vont
mettre chacun casse qui vont choisir un
fauteuil derrière lequel ils vont se
mettre tous les fauteuils pète sauf un
celui qui n'aura pas de détonations aura
gagné son billet pour la laponie ce
qu'ils ont déjà gagné
c'est à dire ceux qui partent déjà comme
jean michel maire maxime gainey daniel
moreau qui n'est pas là ce soir on a
également kelly b dom est dit on a
également qui a gagné isabelle
morini-bosc qu'à gagner son ticket hier
après sa bonne prestation sur le match
du poste et on à bernard montiel
également qui est sélectionné oui les
séries je vais vous demander chacun
votre tour de vous mettre devant un
tabouret chacun votre tour et vous allez
mettre le casque ensuite d'accord vous
mettez sur un tabouret et vous mettez le
casque vraiment vous choisissez
quelqu'un sur le tabouret c'est bon
alors je vous le dit raymond comme vous
ça descendait en premier vous pourrez
être délogés à tout moment ouais alors
quant à patrick dehors les gars vous me
laissez tard c'est en fait c'est celui
qui choisit au dernier qui regrette
gilles vannelet le hnoss n'y a fait il
sera bientôt prenez le 9.5 le 5
si vous voulez un truc déjà pris
pourrait dire non je vaux le tien nar
d'accord il avait eu 3 le 3 vous mettez
mettez devant le 3 tvous dans les trois
blessés le 6 le 6 mettez vous dans le
site kristinn le 2 le 2 mettez vous dans
le dos gérald mathieu j'enlève
l'animateur du passé pour celui du
présent le sac donc vous partez du 5
pour choisissez la paix sans frapper
mais lequel
attention nicolas pernikoff je vais
prendre le dise je vais prendre vite
tourné en qui tu as pris sinon eh bien
non moi je suis pas cher vos camarades
et lui attention vos le 8 c'est parfait
[Rires]
5 à sebala vous sortez moi non pas vous
sortez vous sortez d'un essai amanda
lear la wii a laissé mon poney club à
celui que vous vous les prenez abonnés
on le 4 comprendre le 5 nov
alors jetez rien ah oui j'ai lu des
romans prenez allez-vous sans réussite
mais rien savoir d'elle qu'elle
contamine la séquence
le 4 mars et la lune stikeman ans allez
on y va et je vais prendre le 8 le mythe
amo sorti son coup le haut fourneau et
vous numéro uno les chéris est-ce que
enlevez vos casques d'abord pour
l'instant est-ce que vous êtes tous
content de vos places oui oui j'ai dû
casser le dira si vous s'il vous plaît
excusez moi ouais je prendrais bien de
cette pourquoi mais sécurité le chiffre
les wind et la part de west ham
allez on y va on va démarrer attend avec
hâte en date on avait perdu ses cinq
sacres s'était pas laissée venir
risquent rien non non ce n'est pas une
fête quand même gaffe je sais pas aller
voilà attention maxime kenny en fait
péter le à te fais pas mal hein non pas
de péter l'on savait rien ça n'est rien
c'est bon on se calme
maxime gainey ne gagnera pas deuxième
billet pour la laponie [ __ ] attention
faites-moi péter le 2
tu fais là répète alors jean dire à jean
mounet vous êtes élu me direz vous ne
gagnez pas la laponie jolie isabelle
morini bosc a déjà son ticket si l on
gagne un deuxième
isabelle morini-bosc choisira quelqu'un
le donnera quelque 1 3 2 à céret à 2 to
j'adore l'odeur
voilà près tout ce qu'on appelle le feu
au cul cul on ne voit plus rien ça c'est
un truc belli elle a déjà son ticket si
elle logan ses organes un deuxième cd
ses perf à 10 pour cheveux quel est pour
toi c'est bon c'est rien je vois une
faveur c'est maintenant qu'on paie t on
avait arrêté quand je vois le set
allez bonne ballon change pas bien le
sait si vous voulez qu'elle vous êtes et
vous voulez qu'un frère de sept mois
alors on a 11 ans après nos bougez pas
je laisse le sac le 6 et le secteur
chaud ça que le satellite
gilles verdez allez gilles verdez la
mare été bougé mais t'es marrant dû le
garder
[Rires]
[Musique]
attention c'est quoi pour pour les
téléspectateurs je me tue comme ça tous
ceux qui sont éliminés non mais sans
déconner là çà et là il ne fait pas
comme des jeux à la con à légaliser sais
rien cannes a alors on y va vous vous
êtes éliminé également dorment ça va
attention vous êtes éliminé également
merci
attention à ce que nicolas pernikoff va
venir en laponie ou spy agile qui a
cramé attention et jean michel maire qui
a déjà son ticket pour la laponie
est ce qu'ils vont gagner un deuxième
les séries il n'en reste plus que trois
oh [ __ ] ma soeur c'est pour moi l'art
est il reste donc matthieu delormeau a
vraiment incroyable et benjamin castaldi
aux pisteurs et nord benjamin castaldi
quelle quelle chaîne voulez-vous l'a7
peut-être est-ce voulez-vous l'a7 telles
choses ou les fut le début je veux c'est
faire ma soeur mais alors les chéris
puisque vous voulez tous les trois la
sete
c'est très simple on se barre je fumais
allait mettre notre aux mains derrière
le dos non mais non mais on n'a pas
besoin de voir mains derrière le dos
vous aussi les justes les deux alors ben
on peut qu'aider 3 j'allais mettre votre
maillot jaune à mon top vous sortirez
vaudois il doit vous remettre à un
chiffre d'accord d'accord je compterai
je vais je compterai à partir de
castaldi ok verrez c'est très simple
regardez bien chez vous 3 2 1 tab alors
on a donc 3 +14 +4 8 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 et
limité ou dans bellamy l'été dernier
tigana les îles des canaries alors
maintenant attention et ses motifs et
les polémiques outre les noces est
éliminé evans choisir et patati l'oac de
vos goûts leurs gardes à cette tension
mangala le dos deuxième fois que de
leurs mots que de l'embout et castel 3,2
à temps
5 noeuds cap et bep 4 car oui mais 50 ou
1 2 3 4 5 des gages à gagner donc on
vous connaît lequel le lot 7
mettez vous sur le set je vais prendre
le fait prendre le 6 le système d'apple
mais je suis certain alors attention les
chéris on va d'abord faire cramer
recettes
j'ai pas content je vous le dire on fait
cramer très bon bateau grata gueule
[Rires]
mathieu vous appris votre siège
merger libération des noirs et via ses
ailes gagnant entre castaldi et mathieu
de leurs bruits suspects mathieu
castaldi ouais mathieu si vous qui
décidez puisque vous avez le sentiment
du sénat actuellement castaldi est ce
que est ce que vous choisissez le sec
tout est ce que vous décidez de changer
au dernier moment db j'arrache change
tu vas te faire le garantis m'énerve
quand tu fais ça tu sais quelque chose
change mais c'est pas pour ça
oui je sais on vient de me dire où il
était donc qu'est ce que vous voulez
changer
non je souffre aucun sinon allez non je
garde de cette zac sûr tu la feras pas
ça l'amitié
il va faire péter celui de castaldi si
castaldi ne pète pas castaldi sera
qualifié pour la laponie
c'est castaldi pète c'est moi c'est
matthieu delormeau
mais matthieu delormeau on est vachement
ce soit qui l'arrivée 3 et si ceux ci
n'arrivent
moi je suis impotent plaît à la victoire
modeste
non mais quoi qu'il arrive je vous lis
on aura une explication après la pub
tous les trois et pendant la pub et on
lira aux téléspectateurs que tu pleurais
je voudrais qu'on fasse péter benjamin
castaldi
je ne suis pas convaincu que dumas
pourquoi elle voulait absolument l'a7